Can you spot the problem with this image?
This is the baby photo of our universe.
It shows the whole universe as it was when
it was just 380,000 years old.
Ok, so that doesn’t sound very young for
a baby photo, but if you consider the universe
today to be an 80 year old person, than that
image is the equivalent of a baby pic taken
at 19 hours after birth.
So it truly is a baby photo.
But why can’t we get a photo from an earlier
time than that?
Well, the problem is the universe before 380,000
thousand years after the big bang was so hot
that all the matter in it, all these protons
and electrons was in a state of plasma.
They were all flying all over the place and
any light passing through there would get
scattered or absorbed.
So the whole universe was opaque.
The light couldn’t travel anywhere, until
380,000 years when the universe had expanded
and cooled enough for the protons and the
electrons to get together and form hydrogen
atoms, right, this clear gas.
So finally after bouncing around for 380,000
years like pinballs, these photons could finally
travel out through space.
And there they would go, on these photons
would go for 13.8 billion years.
The whole lifetime of our universe these photons
were just traveling through space, not hitting
anything until they reached our detector.
And that is how we formed this baby image
of our whole universe.
Now, of course, over that time our universe
expanded a lot.
So those photons which started out as ultraviolet
light or visible radiation, blue light, ended
up as microwaves by the time it got to us.
They expanded along with the universe.
And that is why we can’t see the earliest
light in the universe, but we can detect it
with these microwave telescopes.
These microwaves were actually found by accident.
Two radio astronomers, Penzias and Wilson,
were actually trying to take radio images
of certain things in the sky, stars and galaxies,
but they found there was this annoying background
noise when they tried to make their measurements.
So they thought maybe there wasn’t a cable
connected correctly or maybe it was bird poop.
But it turned out it was actually the signal
from the early universe.
And everywhere they pointed their telescope,
they saw exactly the same signal.
I mean, the whole early universe was incredibly
uniform according to their observations.
So the real early baby photo looks like this.
That was the state of the universe at 380,000
years after the big bang.
It was uniform, so incredibly uniform everywhere.
The variations were only about one part in
100,000.
So we built better telescopes and sent them
into space to try to give us the detail.
I mean, we are interested in the variation,
not just the fact that it is totally uniform.
So this is the first blurry baby photo that
we took and we liked that one so much that
we built a better telescope and we got a better
image, a higher resolution image.
Now you can clearly see that the early universe
has these hot spots and cold spots.
And we liked that image so much that we built
an even better telescope and got an even better
image.
This is like the perfect baby photo.
I mean, this is like seeing the eyelashes,
right?
This is so much detail.
You can see the little hot and cold spots.
And those are so important to our existence,
because they show that the early universe
was actually a bit lumpy.
There were places with slightly higher density
and places with slightly lower density.
And that is incredibly important, because
it is the places of higher density that will
gravitationally pull together the matter around
them clumping into stars and galaxies and
the structures that we are a part of.
I mean, without a little bit of non uniformity
we could not be here, because stars and galaxies
would never coalesce.
Now where did those lumps come from?
Well, they seemed to be the signature of quantum
fluctuations, or it is the idea that we are
made of quantum fields and it is impossible
to keep those quantum fields perfectly still.
They are always varying, bubbling a little
bit.
You know, particles popping in and out of
existence.
Heisenberg’s uncertainty principle says
that we cannot keep the uncertainty in energy
down to absolute zero, which means there is
always going to be some matter appearing and
disappearing.
And that seems to be what created the lumpiness
in the universe that we can see.
And it is that which gave rise to all these
major structures like galaxies.
So we should be thankful for this sort of
crazy fluctuation because without it we could
not be here.
But focusing in on the lumps, we forget that
what the true baby photo is, is of incredible
uniformity and that is the problem with this
image.
It is the fact that the whole universe had
basically the same temperature 380,000 years
after the big bang and that doesn’t make
a lot of sense.
I mean, why should that part of the sky be
exactly the same temperature as that part
of the sky?
It is kind of baffling.
And scientists were at a loss with how do
we explain it.
I mean the expectation after the big bang
is that everything would be in a massive jumble.
So this incredible uniformity had to be explained
somehow.
So they proposed something called inflation,
which is fairly straight forward, but a little
bit crazy.
It is the idea that right after the big bang,
we may have had a totally mottled mess, right?
The big bang did not necessarily give us anything
clean or tidy.
But right after the big bang all of the sudden
the universe just expanded incredibly rapidly,
like the likes of which we have never seen
again, just all of the sudden...
The whole universe got huge very fast.
The inflation is proposed to have started
at this time and finished at this time after
the big bang.
I am not making this stuff up.
Like honestly it is nuts.
But the reason that would make the universe
that we see in that baby photo is because
it would stretch out all of the wrinkles.
It would create something quite uniform.
I mean, imagine you are looking at a picture
of a landscape.
You see all these different colors, different
structures, right?
It is very varied.
Now imagine all of the sudden that photo is
expanded in front of you, like...
Now all you are going to see is one color,
because of how much that whole photo has been
blown up.
Well, it is a very similar thing with the
universe.
We imagine that we could see something totally
uniform and totally homogenous if right after
the big bang the whole universe just blew
up.
But this is kind of a crazy idea created to
deal with a problem with that picture.
I mean, is it really true?
Did inflation really happen or is it just
a convenient fiction we have invented to try
to explain this baby photo?
How can we ever figure out what happened before
that 380,000 year barrier?
I mean, we are not going to get any light
from before then.
But maybe there is something else that we
can detect, gravitational waves.
Now the idea of gravitational waves is that
if you wiggle a charge you get electromagnetic
radiation, because you are varying electric
and magnetic fields.
Similarly, if you wiggle some mass, you should
get gravitational waves, because of how they
disturb the gravitational field around them.
I mean, that disturbance should ripple out
through space.
The problem is gravitational waves are incredibly
weak.
So we have been trying to detect them for
a while.
Maybe gravitational waves from two stars orbiting
each other really fast.
But so far on earth we have not be able to
detect their existence.
But here is the idea.
If in that moment of inflation everything
expands out so rapidly, then the gravitational
waves from that moment would stretch and squeeze
all of the matter in the early universe.
And scientists thought we may be able to see
the impact of those gravitational waves on
the baby photo of the universe.
But what we would need to take is an image
so pristine that it not only records where
the hot and cold spots are, it also records
the polarization of the light.
Now the polarization is basically just the
way that the electric field of the light is
oscillating.
So it can oscillate back and forth this way
or it can oscillate back and forth this way.
The idea is we can model what gravitational
waves should do.
They should create a kind of swirl in the
polarization around these hot and cold spots.
We know exactly what it should look like and
that is what scientists have done.
They measured the polarization of the light
coming away from the 380,000 years after the
big bang, all that plasma.
And what did they find?
Exactly what thy predicted would happen if
inflation did occur and gravitational waves
have affected the plasma of the early universe.
That is what everyone is so excited about.
Essentially we are seeing that what we thought
was true at the very tiny fraction of a second
after the big bang, we can see its signature
in light that is only arriving at the earth
right now.
And what is more, we know that quantum gravity
must work, in a way, because that is the earliest
sign that general relativity and quantum mechanics
are working together, something we haven’t
been able to demonstrate before now.
So this is one of the hugest discoveries in
science of all time and certainly my lifetime.
It is a fun time to be learning about science
and thinking about our universe, because we
are just getting new clues into how our whole
universe was born.
When you look at all of the incredible things
in the universe, the galaxies, stars, black
holes, the earth, people, plants, computers,
the internet, just think to yourself, in the
words of Carl Sagan: These are some of the
things that hydrogen atoms do when given 14
billion years of cosmic evolution.
And, in fact, one of the things they do is
create a website where you can download information
at the click of a button.
Audible.com is one of the leading providers
of audio books with a vast range of titles,
over 150,000.
And this week I wanted to recommend a book
by Carl Sagan called Contact which I absolutely
love, because I feel like he correctly sort
of describes the experience of what it is
like to be a young scientist.
I could really relate to the main character.
So if you are into science and you haven’t
read or listened to this yet, you definitely
need to.
And you can download it for free by going
to Audible.com/Veritasium or you can pick
any other book of your choosing for a one
month free trial.
So I want to thank Audible for supporting
me and I want to thank you for watching.